Rob here with a GS news update
Nintendo's upcoming Legend of Zelda for
the Wii U has been delayed previously
expected by the end of 2015 the game now
has no release window at all veterans
series producer Eiji Aonuma said that
rather than target a release date they
want to focus on making the ultimate and
most complete Zelda game how Numa said
development of the game has revealed new
ideas they want to expand on he said the
team has experienced firsthand the
freedom of exploration that hasn't
existed in any zelda game to date we
have discovered several new
possibilities for this game it now feels
like we have the potential to create
something that exceeds my own
expectations this is clearly a
disappointment for any zelda fan but as
with all game delays there is hope that
perhaps this is what is needed for the
game to be the best like what didn't
happen with watch dogs Nintendo has also
announced that they won't be showing the
game at this year's e3 2015 and for all
your gaming news you go ahead you check
out gamespot com / news see you later
you